[موسيقى]
يوصل مفكر الاسلامي الجزائري مالك بن نبي
لا تصمت عن قول الحق ابدا فعندما تضع
لجاما على فمك سيضعون سرجا على ظهرك هل
ابلغوا من قول الامام علي كرم الله وجهه
عندما قال حين سكت اهل الحق عن الباطل
توهم اهل الباطل انهم على حق اذا كنت من
اهل الحق اسدي بكل حب خدمه لاهل الباطل
بين لهم الحق فلربما لا يعلمون انهم على
باطل الى العناوين
من دفن السوريين في حفره التضامن وقع فيها
اطباء اسرائيليون يتلقون عروضا للعمل في
الخليج
اختفاء طفل سوداني كل ستين دقيقه والمجاعه
قادمه
سعيد يعترض على ترتيب الاخبار في
التلفزيون التونسي
وزير اقتصادي لبنان يستفز دوله الكويت
بشحطه قلم
مودي الممنوع من دخول امريكا صار حليفا
للبيت الابيض
هل يقول حجاب المسلم لغير المحجبه انت غير
محتشمه
الدنمارك تشعر بالعزله الدوليه بسبب
اجازتها اهانه الاديان
[موسيقى]
مرحبا في العام 2012 قال السياسي الناصري
المصري حمدين صباحي من القاهره ان دماء
اطفال سوريا ستطارد نظام الاسد حتى
النهايه
فهل ازفه النهايه عند حمدين صباحي ليزور
الاسبوع الماضي الرئيس السوري على راس وفد
من المؤتمر القومي العربي انا تقديري نظام
بشار الاسد بقدر ما اراك من دم في من
الشعب السوري لم يعد قادرا على ان يستمر
لان السوره التي تتعافى الان بعد اكثر من
عشر سنوات من الجراح التي ادخنتها على يد
اعدائها عوض الله السوريين بالقضاء
الالماني فبعد ثلاثه اعوام من البحث
والتحري استطاع خلالها المركز السوري
للعداله والمساءله تق معلومات هامه للشرطه
الفيدراليه الالمانيه في برلين بدا مجرموا
مجزره حفره التضامن بدمشق بالسقوط فيها
ولو بعد حين احمد حمروني وفق تحديد اسمه
الكامل من شبكه ارينت السوريه المعارضه في
قبضه العداله الالمانيه
الالماني بحق المتهم احمد ايضا بعض
الفيديوهات التي يظهر في هذا الشخص مع
الفرع 227 يرتكب انتهاكات في تلك المنطقه
بتلك الفتره موجوده ايضا وهي بحوزه الشرطه
الالمانيه الان نعتقد انها ستكون ادله
كافيه لكن طبعا سيخضع لمحاكمه او راح يكون
عنده اكثر من محامي
اجمعي حاجاتك وارحلي فورا الى تل ابيب
يا اخي الناس تتوجس بتبلش زياره بتخلص
احتلال
طردت اداره فندق في القاهره عارضه ازياء
اجنبيه بعدما تبينت جنسيتها الاسرائيليه
رغم انها تدفع بالعمله الصعبه لكن
استقبالها اصعب في ثقافه الشعب المصري
الحر اداره الفندق وموظفوه هم شخصيه فوق
السلطه هذا الاسبوع في غضون يوم تقريبا من
وصولها اكتشف الفندق الذي تقيم فيه انها
اسرائيليه وفي لحظتها طلب منها مغادره
الفندق على الفور قالت زانكو لقد شعرت
بالتوتر الشديد وشعرت بالاهانه حقا تحدثت
اكثر من وسيله اعلام اسرائيليه بارزه عن
عروض يتلقاها اطباء اسرائيليون للعمل في
الخليج لاسيما في الامارات والبحرين بعد
ظاهره تسرب النخب من تل ابيب المرافق لما
يسمى بالثوره القضائيه على خلفيه ما اعتبر
بلطجه من رئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو
وعبثا منه بالتشريعات وبالقضاء كشفت وسائل
اعلام اسرائيليه انه بعد التشريع قامت
مستشفيات ومنظمات طبيه في دول الخليج وفي
الامارات والبحرين تحديدا بالتوجه الى
اطباء اسرائيليين للعمل لديها بشروط جذابه
في المقابل ربما يعتبر البعض ان التطبيع
اضر باسرائيل حيث فتح نافذه جديده لهجره
نخبها العلميه التي باتت تفكر ايضا
بالحصول على جواز سفر اخر والمثل يقول من
هجر سيهجر ولو بعد حين نقابه الاطباء
تحاول صدموجه الاطباء الذين يهددون
بالانتقال الى الخارج ما قد يتسبب بضرر
هائل للمنظومه الصحيه في اسرائيل ابرز ما
اراد نتنياهو الحصول عليه في التعديلات
القضائيه هو من من منصبه لاي سبب كان ما
عدا الاسباب الصحيه العقليه والجسديه يعني
اذا صار معه خرف او سلس دائم على سبيل
المثال وفق التعديل يمنع عزل رئيس حكومه
من منصبه الا لاسباب صحيه فقط وهو ما يمنع
عزل بنيامينه يهو رئيس الحكومه استدخل في
الاصلاحات القضائيه رغم القضايا الجنائيه
المقدمه ضده في المحاكم
على صحه السلامه وبدون حروب يعاني كثيرا
من السودانيين من سوء التغذيه بسبب سوء
اداء الحكومات المتعاقبه واخفاقها في
استثمار ثروات البلاد اما اليوم فقد رفعت
معارك الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع اعداد
الجائعين الى اكثر من خمسه ملايين انسان
فهل يكتفي جنرالات الحروب والانقلابات
بهذا الرقم ام انهم اقسموا على ان يجوعوا
شعب السودان والشعوب المجاوره عن بكره
ابيها قبل اندلاع الصراع في السودان بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع كان يعاني نحو
15 مليون سوداني من انعدام الامن الغذائي
في بلد يقال عنه انه لو احسن اداره موارده
لاصبح سله الغذاء للمنطقه
اليوم بات يتوجع اكثر من 20 مليون سوداني
من الم الجوع وانعدام الغذاء اي ما يعادل
نحو 43% من سكان البلاد يقول تقرير
المشترك للامم المتحده ومنظمات انسانيه
يشكل عدد اطفال السودان نصف عدد اجمالي
السكان لكن امراء الحروب لم يتركوهم
بحالهم فادخلوا طفوله السودان موسوعه
جينيس برقم مفجع حيث يختفي طفل كل ساعه
قتلا او اصابه او اختطافا منذ اندلاع
الحرب الراهده طفل كل ساعه في عداد
المصابين والمفقودين الى الابد
هكذا بادت ساعه الزمن في السودان منذ
اندلاع الحرب التي تجاوزت 100 يوم وتحصد
ارواح الجميع لا سيما الاطفال دون هواته
في تقرير حديث تدق منظمه اليونيسف ناقوس
الخطر
الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد انهى مهام رئيسه
الحكومه نجلاء بودن دون الاعلان عن
الاسباب وعين خلفا لها احمد الحساني الذي
تردد انه تلقى تعليمه الجامعي في كليه
الحقوق بجامعه تونس حيث كان سيد استاذا
فيها الرئيس التونسي يحدد اولويات الحكومه
الجديده خلال موكب تسلم احمد الحشاني
لمهامي لكن التغيير الذي قام به سعيد على
راس الحكومه لم يقنع قوى سياسيه الشخص
الذي عين على راس الحكومه شخصيه غير
معروفه تماما ما هي ارائه وما هي رؤيته ما
هو برنامجه ما هي خبرته في توحيد الناس
وجمعهم في الحياه السياسيه لا شيء لمن لم
يتسنى له سماع صوت رئيسه الحكومه المعفاه
من مهامها نجلاء بودن خلال فتره ولايتها
لها اخيرا مقطع صوتي نادر اثناء توديعها
الرئيس
ولفت تصريح غريب لها حين قالت ولينا اصحاب
انو سيد احمد رئيس الحكومه الجديد سيد
الرئيس
الحكومه ان شاء الله بالتوفيق والنجاح
الرئيس سعيد استدعى مديره التلفزيون
التونسي العام الى قصر قرطاج واعترض
امامها على ترتيب الاخبار في النشرات
ترتيب غير بريء بحسب الرئيس الذي استغرب
ايضا عن ودنه حلقه تلفزيونيه بالزمن
الجميل وهو لم يكن زمنا جميلا برايه
المدير العام
لمؤسسه
التلفزه الوطنيه التونسيه
عديد البرامج التي تبث فضلا عن نشرات
الاخبار
وترتيب الانباء داخل هذه النشرات
ليست بالبريئه اطلاقا بالامس فقط صدفه
شاهدت
جزءا من برنامج تم بثه
تحت عنوان الزمن الجميل لحسين من هذا
القبيل
وما هو بالزمن الجميل
لو كان جميلا لما كان الوضع
على هذا النحو التلميذ ليس له اي شيء على
الاطلاق النقابه الوطنيه للصحفيين
التونسيين استنكرت ما وصفته بالتدخل
السافر والمباشر لرئيس الجمهوريه في
الاعلام والذي وصل الى حد ترتيب فقرات
النشرات الاخباريه والمحتوى والضيوف
معتبره ذلك سابقه خطره لم يقدم عليها غيره
تقول نقابه الصحفيين لكن بعض الموالين
يقولون كما ان رئيس الجمهوريه هو القائد
الاعلى للقوات المسلحه فيحق له ان يكون
الرئيس التحرير العام في البلاد
وزير الاقتصاد اللبناني في حكومه تصريف
الاعمال امين سلام والمحسوب على الرئيس
السابق ميشال عون انضم الى سلسله الوزراء
الاشكاليين الذين يتفنون في الاساءه
لعلاقات لبنان بالدول الخليجيه بالذات
يقول امين ان الكويت تستطيع بسخطه قلم اي
بامضاء سريع اتخاذ قرار ببناء صوامع القمح
للبنان وزير الاقتصاد المنتهي صلاحيه
حكومته اعلن انه يتحدث باسم الشعب
اللبناني مع انه ليس نائبا منتخبا ومنه
مختار حتى بحاره وانا بعثت رساله
الخارجيه من ثلاثه اسابيع اطالب باسم
الشعب اللبناني مش باسم الدوله اللبنانيه
اعاده بناء اهراءات بلبنان مش بس ببيروت
حفاظا على الامن الغذائي الاموال موجوده
وانا تواصلت مع وزاره الخارجيه وعرفت انه
بصندوق التنميه الكويتي في اموال موجوده
يمكن بشخطه الم اليوم يؤخذ قرار انه
لبنان وزير خارجيه الكويت يستنكر تصريحات
وزير الاقتصاد
ويطلب منه سحبها فيما تساءل معلقون هل
سيطلب امين سلام لاحقا الاطلاع على موازنه
الحكومه الكويتيه قبل اقرارها اعرب وزير
الخارجيه الكويتيه الشيخ سالم صباح
استنكار الكويت واستغرابها الشديدين
لتصريحات وزير الاقتصاد اللبناني امين
سلام حيث اكد عبر بيان وزاره الخارجيه بين
التصريح يتنافى مع ابسط الاعراف السياسيه
وان الكويت ترفض رفضا قاطعا اي تدخل
بشؤونها الداخليه داعيا لبنان الى سحب
التصريح حرصا على العلاقات ثنائيه بين
البلدين ابينا اسلام قدم
[موسيقى]
معصم الوزير واستاذ امين سلام لابس ساعه
تقدر ب 280 الف دولار
عم تطلع تشحد
باسم 80 الف دولار معكم مصاري اذا
بتجمعوهن قادرين تعمروا اربعه وخمس دول
مثل لبنان معكم مصاري قادرين تسدوا الدين
العام اللي هو 300 مليار دولار عام وبين
مصاري الموضعين اللي راحوا بالبنوكي معكم
مصاري ما بتاكلها النيران في المقابل
ناشطون كويتي يستغرب الحمله على امينه
سلام ويعتبرها قاسيه فالرجل لم يفعل غير
التمني باسم الاخوه والناس لبعضها الرجل
قال بكل صراحه ليس لنا كحكومه ولكن للشعب
حتى تقفوا مع الشعب اللبناني
كانت رده فعل غريبه من الكويتيين وصار
عندنا ما نتحمل الناس ودائما نبي نصعد كل
هذا لانه قالب شخطه قلم ممكن الموضوع يحله
وردوا على الناس وفي وزارات ومؤسسات
والرجل ما كان يعني كان يقصد ان الموضوع
ببساطه انه ممكن ينحل من قبلكم وتساعدون
اشقائكم
[موسيقى]
لم تصدر السلطات الهنديه امرا باغلاق
المساجد في مدينه جروغرام وانما نشد
مسؤولون مسلمون محليون المصلين باي يؤدوا
الصلاه في منازلهم للحد من اعداد القتل في
صفوفهم بعد التوحش مجموعه هندوسيه متطرفه
على اهل المدينه ذات الغالبيه المسلمه اثر
تعرض موكب هندوسي فيها لرشق الصبيان
بالحجاره
مثل هذا العنف الطائفي المفتوح يعيش فيه
وعليه حزب بهرات يا جنات الحاكم بزعامه
رئيس الوزراء الهندي نارين درامودي صديقه
3/4 العرب مسجدوا
بقوات الشرطه السلطات الهنديه كثفت وجودها
الامني في ولايه هاريانا الواقعه جنوبا
نيودلهي لتخفيف الاحتقان الطائفي قبل
يومين فقط قتل شخص هنا في هجوم يرجح انه
نفذ بدافع الثار وتعرض مسجد اخر ثلاثاء في
منطقه سونا ايضا لهجوم عشرات الاشخاص فتيل
العنف كان قد اشتعل يوم الاثنين جنوب
العاصمه الهنديه تحديدا في منطقه نوح ذات
الاغلبيه المسلمه حيث اقدمت مجموعه على
رشق موكب دينيا هندسي بالحجاره كيف تحول
نارين دربودي من شخص غير مرغوب فيه بدخول
الولايات المتحده بسبب ما يوصف بتوجهاته
الطائفيه
الى حليف مقرب من الولايات المتحده التي
تدعي حرصها على حقوق الاقليه المسلمه
الايغور وتدعو الى محاسبه الصين على ما
تصفه باباده الايجار فيما تتغاضى واشنطن
عن مذابح الهندوس المتطرفين بحق المسلمين
في الهند وفي حمام دم بدعم حكومي مفتوح
بحسب المنظمات الحقوقيه العالم يفرش
السجاد الاحمر لرئيس الوزراء الهندي فيما
هو مستمر في سيره متجاهلا الهجمات العرقيه
المتزايده التي يشنها اتباعه من الهندوس
الانتهاكات الكبيره للحريه الدينيه كما
وصفتها واشنطن سابقا كانت سببا جعلها تمنع
مودي من الحصول على تاشيره دبلوماسيه
لزيارتها عام 2005 لمده عشر سنوات قبل ان
يحتضنه البيت الابيض بقوه
جعله احد اهم الحلفاء ليس الهندوس
المتطرفون فقط من يعتدون على المسلمين في
شبه القاره الهنديه فتنظيم داعش كان حاضرا
ايضا لتفجير انتحاري تبناه ضد تجمع سياسي
لجمعيه علماء الاسلام في مدينه خان بشمال
غرب باكستان اوقع اربعه وخمسين قتيلا على
الاقل قالت وكاله الانباء ان نصفهم تقريبا
قاصرون
وشيع مئات الباكستانيين ضحايا التفجير
الانتحاري الذي تقطن فيه داعش المسلمين
باسم الاسلام وفق تعليق المشيعين
هبه سعديه اول سيده في تحكيم مباريات كره
القدم العالميه تضع الحجاب لتخطف بعض
اللاعبه المغربيه نهيل بنزين الاضواء في
كاس العالم للسيدات باستراليا ونيوزيلندا
وذلك بعد رفع الفيفا الحظر عن الحجاب على
ارض الملعب ازيل الجليد عن كاتب فرنسي
فكره متجمد منذ العصور الوسطى اقصائي
الغائي يحتاج ادبه الى اعاده فرمته كما
وصف هو اهان حجاب المراه المسلمه ووصفه
بانه مفهوم رجعي واعتبر ان حجاب البطله
الرياضيه المغربيه نهيل بنزينه يقول
للنساء غير المحجبات انتن غير محتشيمه
[موسيقى]
غريبه هذه المعادله هل الراهبه تقول ايضا
لغيرها انتن غير محتشمه هل من يذهبوا الى
الكنيسه يوم الاحد يتهم من لا يذهب اليها
بالالحاد هل من يمارس الرياضه يقول لمن لا
يمارسها انت بليد وكسول هل من يستحم كل
يوم اسمعني منيح ايها الكاتب الفرنسي اذا
ترجموها لك يقول لك انت وسخ يسال خليل
رفيقه للشاب
صحف مغاربيه تعلق باستثناء فرنسا العالم
يحتفي باللاعبه المغربيه المحجبه نهيل
بنزينه هل تعلمون ان باريس التي تلقب
بعاصمه النور منوره بمقدرات المسلمين فهي
تعتمد على ثلاث دول ذات غالبيه مسلمه هي
كازاخستان والنيجر واوز باكستان من اجل
مدها باليورانيوم لانتاج الكهرباء بالطاقه
النوويه ثم يسفه بعض الفرنسيين وسياسيين
واعلامييهم دين الغالبيه العظمى لشعوب هذه
الدول الانقلاب الحاصل في النيجر اثار
مخاوف بشان انشطه مجموعه اورانو الفرنسيه
لليورانيوم التي تدير منجما كبيرا في
البلاد وطرح تساؤلات عده عن مدى اعتماد
فرنسا على اليورانيوم النيجيريه خاصه ان
حوالي 70% من توليد الطاقه الكهربائيه في
يعتمد على الطاقه النوويه واعتمدت بشكل
اساسي على ثلاث دول لتامين احتياجاتها من
اليورانيوم الطبيعي من بينها النيجر التي
تغطي نسبه 20% من احتياجات فرنسا ضربتين
على الراس بتوجع يقول المثل اما مكروم
فيقول لقاده مخابراته ضربه النيجر بعد مال
امر صعب علينا صحيفه لوكانار انسيني تكشف
كواليس اجتماع عسكري مغلق في قصر الاليزي
مكرون يؤنب رئيس المخابرات الفرنسيه برنار
لتقصير جهاز الامن في تقدير الاوضاع في
النيجر
هذا ما قالته صباح اليوم صحيفه كنر انشيني
المتخصصه في نشر كواليس السياسه الفرنسيه
تشعر رئيسه الوزراء الدنماركيه
بان بلادها معرضه لخطر العزله الدوليه وان
هناك خطرا امديا ملموسا بسبب الاعتداءات
التي ترخصها دولتها على المصاحف الشريفه
اما السويد التي اسمعت العالم الاسلامي
الاسبوع الماضي كلاما معسولا عن نيتها
والدنمارك حضر تجمعات حرق المصحف الشريف
فقد اتت فعلا جديدا من افعالها القبيحه
والمدانه دوليا
بترخيصها رسميا لتكرار الحرق وهذه المره
على يد امراه من اصل ايراني هل يعلم ويفهم
هؤلاء المعتادون ان المصحف الشريف الذي
يسيئون اليه
يتمنى الملايين بل مئات الملايين ان تكون
اياته الكريمه اخر ما ينطقون به في هذه
الحياه كما حصل هذا الاسبوع مع مؤذن
فلسطيني في غزه بفلسطين حضره الموت اثناء
قراءته القران الكريم
قبيل صلاه الفجر ليس الغريب غريب الشام
واليمن ان الغريب غريب اللحد والكفن
ختاما عندما طغى فرعون في البلاد وبلغ
غايه العتو والاستكبار ارسل الله اليه
نبيه موسى عليه السلام ليدعوه بالحكمه
والموعظه الحسنه لكن فرعون استكبر على
الحق وادعى الربوبيه وهو اعرف الناس بانه
كذاب اجوف اذا شرب شربه ماء وتعثر خروجها
يموت فكيف يحيي وكيف يميت لكن التكبر
والهوس بالتسلط على رقاب الناس وارزاقهم
ورضوخ المظلومين لظلمه ونظم الشعراء قصائد
في مدحه وملاحقه مخابراته الخارجين عن
طوعه وتسويغ المحنكين صوابيه فكره وحتميه
تابيد استبداده امور دفعته لاي يستخف قومه
فيطيعوه واعتقد بانه ارفع من البشر وظن
انه كبير حتى غرغر حلقومه بالطوفان ليقول
له البحر انت مهما كبرت صغير الى اللقاء
مهما كبرت صغير انا مهما عليت مش فوق مش
ممكن يوم نتغير دي الدنيا غروب شروق
[موسيقى]